[Music]
welcome to lecture number 10 in this
this series yeah we're in the middle of
our third year each year we do four one
ancient one
medieval that's what we're doing today
one early modern and one late modern you
know like 20th century or so sometimes
19th century thinkers like Nietzsche so
the idea behind this this lecture series
philosophers and myths of history is to
look at people who were in the midst of
their their historical situation which
definitely applies to Augustine and were
shaped and formed by it and what they
were doing but who also had a reciprocal
influence in making a contribution not
just to later times but to their own
times so there's kind of a back and
forth influence from the history and the
context to the thinker there are
thoughts that ideas changing the world
that they live in and this definitely
applies to just st. Augustine so what I
thought I would talk about in this one
is the first of the historical situation
in the context and you know mapping out
a bit of that and then talk about
Augustine's life within that that
framework so I've got a timeline for you
I'll be concentrating more on the the
one side of the timeline you know the
events in the Roman Empire and the
church and then looking at Augustine
himself and then you know I thought we'd
talk about some of his ideas there's no
way we're gonna summarize all of his
main ideas even in in a lecture like
this he's just so rich and fertile in
thoughts that have made some interesting
contributions so I thought I'd go over
some if you guys have any that you want
to talk about in particular if you've
you know read the confessions or the
City of God or anything like that or you
know any other things catch your eye we
can certainly talk more about them and
then I want to talk about his influence
on
Christian thought and thereby you know
Western culture all the way down to the
present because he's he's somebody who's
still read and taught you can't say that
necessarily about all the people that
we've covered but Augustine is really a
centrally influential person and it's
interesting as people either love him or
hate him for the most part yeah there's
a lot of you know Augustine being this
terrible guy who screwed everything up
with his notion of original sin and the
way that he made sense of it and then
there's a lot more receptive and you
know sort of fruitfully interpretive
views on Augustine as well and he was
very exciting to read you know I brought
along the confessions which probably is
the one book this is a very old version
of it but it's probably the one book
that's that's most commonly read and
it's you know it's one of the first
tell-alls of history this guy goes into
great detail about all the things that
are going on within his life and and you
know how it oriented him to God
eventually but it takes a long time to
get there and it's really you know
exciting stuff to to read I also
actually wanted you know if you're
willing to indulge me to tell you a
little story about Augustine and how he
fit into my actually studying philosophy
so you guys are good with that okay so
when I was in high school I went to a
Catholic Memorial just down the road in
Waukesha and we had a philosophy class I
thought philosophy sounded kind of cool
and I took it and it was terrible we had
this textbook that was it didn't
introduce you to any you know real
readings it was all sort of predigested
stuff and the instructor was he might be
a good teacher now I don't know but he
wasn't a great teacher back then
he you know he wanted us to read this
this textbook and to get across the
ideas and to discuss them in class but
within very narrow confines and I
remember getting an F on a test because
I totally missed one essay question
where he was asking about you know
arguments for God's existence and you
know if I was God would I have made it
easy or difficult to prove my own
existence and I said I would have made
it extremely difficult and then anybody
who succeeded in doing it I would kill
him with lightning because that way it
would keep the whole game open for
anybody else to come along and continue
it and he gave me a total zero on the
thing and said when I asked about that I
said you're asking us what we would
choose it's our opinion no no the test
presupposes the class so it was one of
these classes where you know the answers
around the board and we're supposed to
write them down and then regurgitate it
which is really the opposite of
philosophy so so I thought well
philosophy that's not really for me
now the next semester after that oh and
I took that as a religion credit right
because that was how you took philosophy
in Catholic high schools the next
semester we had sacraments and there was
a nun who's gonna be teaching it and she
had a reputation for being very dry and
I was like God is gonna be a terrible
class but now there's a sad part to this
which is she got sick and then died but
that actually turned out good for me in
part because they brought in this
substitute teacher and they did it very
last-minute so I don't think they
screened him all that much and because
if they had maybe they wouldn't have
hired him now he said the first day at
class
I'm an Augustinian convert and you know
we're all like who's this little guy -
kind of had a shaved head look very
monkish and he said yeah I'm from
Seattle so that's a long way right you
know and back then Seattle was like the
Carthage of Augustine's day like a
hotbed of anything you can think about
lots of drugs lots of sex
lots of all sorts of mixes of those yeah
yeah I mean anything you can you can
think of what's that oh yeah there was a
coffee culture I mean the coffee culture
is the teh mistakes right so he said
there's very few people out there who
are Christians I'm one of them and I I
got converted by you know in part
reading Augustine's Confessions and now
you know I was like oh you know and he
went out and he told some of his story
in class he didn't get into any great
details but he said Augustine is my
patron saint because he's so relatable
you know he got into a cult and he got
into these these love affairs and he you
know wanted to change his life but
couldn't quite make it stick you know he
kept relapsing over and over again just
like the rest of us and so he said I'm
gonna teach you about Augustine because
Augustine talks about the sacraments but
before I talk about Augustine I'm gonna
have to do some preparatory work with
you so I'm gonna have to teach you about
Plato and then I'll have to teach you
something you know to contrast with that
I'll have to teach you about Aristotle
and then after we do that then we'll
talk about Augustine and his life and
the cult that he got into that man akise
and then you know if we have some extra
time we'll figure out what to do with
that he did enough talking about Freud
and Jung and Adler well he talked about
him once he got to Augustine but the
whole idea was to give us a framework
now most of the students hated it
because he would you know he would put
some things on the board and then he
would lecture and he would have us you
know have discussions he wanted to know
what we thought and you know whether we
could compare it and how would you you
know how would you think this the way
Aristotle's thinking it how would you
think of the way Augustine is thinking
it and so most of the students were like
what what are the answers you know
what's gonna be on the test
yeah well I was it was very foreign to
us
I thrived with it I loved it and that
was my real introduction to philosophy I
didn't become an Augustinian yeah at
that time I was actually out of the
church you know one of the things that
was cool about Catholic Memorial as they
were they were fine with me like you
know so long as I didn't you know cause
any problems saying that I wasn't I
wasn't Catholic anymore you know they
think they thought I needed some rope
you know before and I'd have to cut and
make my own way back well I suppose
there's that although I think I had a
scholarship if I remember right cuz I
had high test scores but then so this
guy this guy who was influenced by
Augustine turned out to be a very
important influence on me I never
thought I would be doing philosophy but
when then when I went to the college and
they said well what major do you want to
have and I looked down the list I sought
philosophy I was like well I'm that's
interesting stuff I've done that before
well there there weren't that many
majors there was Lakeland College so I
think there may be 20 majors total 26
something like that and yeah so so
anyway that that's that story let's talk
about the historical situation so
Augustine is in the fourth century AD
and he lives into the the 5th century
good ways and that's a very tumultuous
time for the Roman Empire I mean you
really can't say that there ever was a
time in which the Roman Empire was
completely secure and everybody was
getting along with each other and things
were smooth from that point on I don't
think you can even say there was like a
five year period where that took place
but the the fourth and fifth century
things are really going downhill and so
imagine you know the Roman Empire by
that time is not just a political entity
it's an entire culture it's tied in with
the Latin language but there's also a
lot of local languages it's
Hut in with a lot of institutions a lot
of ways of doing things and they've got
a political system that largely become
you know unwieldy it's it's no longer
that that useful for the the situations
that they're facing as a matter of fact
that's another thing that happens over
and over again with in Rome is you know
things that are good for this particular
crisis turn out to be restrictive for
this crisis over here by their time
they're thinking in terms of empire so
you've got a ruler but it's become such
a big affair that you actually have
multiple emperors sometimes it'll be
just one guy in charge but usually he'll
find that too big of a job so he'll try
to appoint somebody else and this is
usually within a family context so you
don't have a great talent pool to draw
upon you know you use your family
because you think you can trust them as
it turns out a lot of the times you
can't but you can trust them more than
people who aren't related to you now if
somebody's really really talented you
might bring them in and make them part
of your family by adopting them and that
happened a lot in the Roman Empire too
but you also had to be constantly
worried about your your own troops
revolting against you or some of your
courtiers you know engaging in factions
against you and so this has been going
on for centuries and why is it so
important to have a strong leader in
charge for these Romans is that will
they just like you know toughness or
something like that what are they facing
like from the outside if you think back
to you know your ancient history or
think about this how did they fall
how did Rome in the west end up
collapsing
I'm sorry to be so good where was this
point in time where was that the park oh
well what's late there because they're
about to collapse but well fourth
century so the the 300s and the early
400s
oh when did it begin mm so where was
this oh well so it kind of depends on
like what you want to call the official
starting point but the Rome the Roman
Commonwealth let's call it all right
goes back into like the 700s BC so it's
been going on for about a thousand years
but is a small at first well so that's a
that's an interesting point if we're
thinking about the arc in terms of the
West we're almost at the end of it
although a lot of these Roman
institutions will survive the fall of
Rome and get sort of rebuilt up again
now if you're thinking about the East
they don't actually go under until a
thousand years later so you know Rome in
in the Greek speaking areas around
Constantinople survives much longer than
it does in the West you know you get
these parts well no the Empire itself
yeah yes yeah exactly yeah the Byzantine
Empire is is Roman and you know we
always talk about these barbarian
invasions right these Germans come in
and raise a lot of health but the
Germans have been you know different
tribes of them had been assimilating in
in the Roman Empire for a couple hundred
years the Romans had begun to start
relying upon Germans and and Gauls and
other people for their military forces
they use them the some of them were
mercenaries some of them would just be
like given grants of areas some of them
work sort of like alliances of
desperation you know you turn one tribe
against the other and actually some of
these leaders come eventually from from
non-roman stock because amazing yeah I
mean yeah well you're drawing upon the
talent that you can find and and you
know by this time really you could you
could be Emperor and be from any part of
the Empire it's it's no longer connected
just with the city of Rome or even Italy
I mean Augustine is a great example he's
from North Africa he probably spoke a
Punic language before he learned Latin
his mother may have been a Berber and
his father you know most likely a Roman
Roman become very cosmopolitan in that
sense but it was more like a who's in
who's supporting the system and who's
disrupting it so that's the political
situation it very oversimplified
and then you've got the religious
situation and this makes it even more
complicated within the Roman Empire you
know you have this traditional Roman
religion right and it's a whole system
of different polytheistic called some
you know more important some connected
with the state some of them not
connected with the state a whole bunch
of different observances rituals
festivals not one big system that like
you know so there was it's not like
there was one calendar that everybody
had to get on and make everything make
sense
and a lot of people would practice that
but didn't really believe in it
including some of the high priests
Cicero who's writing much earlier tells
us that some of the priests are like
laughing as they're carrying out the
sack
physis because they're like lasers for
these stupid peasants over here who
still believe in this stuff
pagan really means something like like
country bumpkin so a lot of the elite
you know they may go along with that but
they think that stuff's kind of nonsense
and they were much more attracted to to
philosophy or to other religions
Christianity you know starts out as a
persecuted religion for really the first
two hundred two hundred fifty years of
its life within the Roman Empire and
it's persecuted in part because it's not
very well understood the Romans knew
about Jews because the Jews had been
around for quite a while and we're
spread all throughout you know the Roman
Empire and they thought Jews were really
strange I've got all these different
things that they do and they don't do
but you know and every once in a while
they revolt and then they have to be put
down but for the most part you know you
know what you've got going on when
Christians come on the scene nobody
really knows what to make of them you
know what what is all this stuff about
like eating their their Savior and
drinking blood and and this guy who is
put up on this cross which is you know
sort of way of trying to destroy
criminals they're worshipping Him what
would that what what's with these these
crazy people and a lot of Christians
were you know fairly low class too so
there's some elitism in there by you
know the second century you're getting
some important intellectuals
articulating what the Christian faith is
about and some of them are some other
are actually writing to Roman Empire
Roman emperors you know saying here's
what you know here's what we actually
believe here's how we fit in with the
philosophies that you're familiar with
here's how what we think about the old
religion
please stop persecuting us they write
these apologies what's up yeah yeah the
idea was you educate
people who have the authority and then
maybe they'll oh it's in both sides this
is really yeah so you know that the key
dividing line is really between the west
which is primarily Latin speaking
although you know people have their own
local languages like in Africa Egypt
always had its own language we call it
Coptic and then the East which was
largely by that time Greek speaking
except for if you went further east in
which case they were Aramaic speaking
but usually the Romans didn't hold too
much of that territory so you know you
think about a age' minor what's not is
Turkey
parts of the you know Middle East Egypt
they they'd usually hold a lot of that
that the Balkans were under Roman
control though sometimes they lose
control over that all of that area was
Greek speaking and then everything west
so that was a useful dividing line you
know and sometimes one person had just
be in charge of like one territory but
now the the Christian religion as it
starts spreading out and it becomes more
and more articulated and sophisticated
it develops into a number of different
groups not only split along linguistic
lines like you know we think about
though the Catholic West you know Latin
and the Orthodox East and also there was
a Coptic in Syriac East as well but it
also got split along doctrinal lines
ideas about you know what the religion
is supposed to be focused on so this is
on that that handout that that
perspectives there's a you know what we
now it is just sort of call Christianity
is what at that time would have been you
know viewed as Orthodox or Catholic
Christianity these are the ones who win
battles between the heresies at that
time you have not only you know
Catholics or Orthodox and at that time
they mean basically the same thing
calling other people heretics you have
all these other people who are calling
who are called heretics calling each
other and the Catholics heretics because
this word heretic comes from hide races
and Greek which means to choose to take
this rather than this and so you know
one of the biggest ones at the time was
the Arian heresy and they were very
powerful they they controlled
Constantinople for quite a while many of
the bishops were Aryans and it was it
was kind of a you know it's
understandable why people might be
attracted to it one of the ways of
trying to make sense of this well you
know Jesus Christ is both God and man at
the same time you've got this Trinity
with Father Son Holy Spirit what what
are you talking about sort of businesses
say let's let's straighten this out so
you've got God the Father the creator
he's the one in charge and then
everything else is sort of lesser so
this this Jesus guy in that case and
there's a couple different stories that
get told about how this works he's
created you know he's something that the
father makes and you know he's really
great he's a nice guy
great teacher and all that but he's not
the father so the father is really the
the main you know the main show and then
everything else just kind of goes
downward to us poor saps as human beings
from there so it was nontrinitarian it
was viewing Jesus is just a particularly
good good guy it could have been the son
of God but son of God means something
very different for them and you know in
places were they controlled the
religious institutions they tended to
push the Orthodox out in places
the Orthodox controlled they tended to
push the Aryans out there was another
group that was primarily in just in
North Africa called the Donatists and
they even had a whole different issue
they in their view if a priest wasn't
completely pure meaning you know free of
all sin then everything that priest did
was no good yeah really
this is not just about the priests it
was about anybody else so like if I'm if
I'm gonna pray for you say oh you know
I'm gonna go have an operation next week
pray for me if I'm not completely
sinless then my prayers don't do any
good
you know so what do we need to do that
well I have to be very very sure that
I'm pure so I have two very ascetic life
in order to to do that they you know
controlled some of the the churches as
well and they again same sort of dynamic
when they were in charge they'd push the
other Christians out and vice versa
Pelagianism winds up being another major
issue in in that time Pelagius is a monk
who teaches in Rome and he his doctrine
that Augustine would directly combat is
this notion that we were really damaged
by the fall of human beings or at least
we're not so damaged that we can't like
win heaven back by our own work you know
we we can and in a way it's kind of
liberating if you if you think that is
well it's up to you whether you're a bad
person or a good person right you don't
need any help from God just do it
yourself it's kind of a bootstrapper
religious philosophy right so these are
all things that are going out and
there's other heresies as well that
they're struggling against and these
really split the church you know there's
there's this interesting sort of
interplay not just between these
religious bodies and each other and the
other religious bodies but between them
and state
power so what if the Emperor himself is
an Aryan that means that everybody else
is in trouble what if the Emperor is
belonging to another group well it means
the other people are probably going to
be in trouble and and interestingly
Christianity was not the state religion
at that time it was one of the tolerated
religions
Constantine often gets talked about is
like making Christianity official he
made it official in the sense that you
could now practice Christianity without
being killed for it
but it wasn't the one single religion
you have you know Judaism Christianity
of all different types the the old you
know Roman religion all kind of working
side by side with each other and then
there's also this other thing
manic ism you guys heard of this before
so Manny was he was a sage and he
created all the best way to describe
it's it's sort of a fusion of Buddhism
Christianity and so Astron ISM the the
religion of you know Iran at that time
with Manny saying all three of these are
good but I'm the final revelation and
they they you know he wrote religious
texts and he had followers and they had
rituals and they incorporated all sorts
of things it became one of the dominant
religions in ancient times well I mean
cult comes from the word for religion
koltes all of these were were you know
all these have some of the
characteristics that we associate with
cults you know very strong in group
identity very often like even with the
Orthodox Christians they wouldn't reveal
all the secrets to you until they knew
that you could be relied upon you know
and then you know there was some sort of
enforcement of Orthodoxy within and the
manna Keys had this incredibly complex
you know cosmology with all these
different being
doing different things augustin belong
to this for a while he was attracted to
this the manic ISM yeah so stretched all
the way from the West the western part
of the Western Roman Empire all the way
to China well the entire Silk Road
really I mean it originates it
originates in the Middle East and then
it just spreads and they were they were
good at that's sort of saying well hey
what you guys are doing over there hey
we're doing that too you know and we
we've got the better version of it and
so it takes on a lot of different local
forms you can say and and sometimes they
get you know they'd get persecuted by
different groups I would say the thing
that really
besides the Christians and the West
persecuting the Manicheans and driving
them out the thing that was really the
death knell was the rise of Islam coming
through and then because the Manicheans
tried to make the case that they were
really you know on the same page and
most of the Muslims weren't happening
weren't having that's right you know and
in China they would get persecuted
sometimes because the Chinese government
would say listen these Manicheans are
saying that they're they're really
Buddhists but they're not really
Buddhists let's get rid of them because
people they're confusing people yeah no
never didn't make it that far there I
mean at the time so man manning is in
the third century and the 200s and then
it spreads like gangbusters within about
a century it's not really I mean by in
the West it winds up more or less
disappearing it goes underground in a
few places but it's more or less gone by
the end of the
fifth century living you know it existed
in other parts of the East for a while
and it was very organized that hadn't
even had a church had a monastic order
you know different ones from Manon for
women and then there is also this sort
of layperson group that that agustin
belong to the the hearers the ones who
are there to listen to the the message
so this is the backdrop of Augustine's
life so when you look at his life he's
born about you know the middle part of
the fourth century and this place is the
ghast a it's kind of a small town in
North Africa and he sent to this place
Madera to study rhetoric you might say
well why the hell would he have to study
then well that rhetoric is the art of
persuasion and it involves a lot of
study of language and rhetoric was
viewed as one of the arts that you would
learn to to make it into civil service
into into government and so you know you
could look at it as Augustine's dad
Patricius is investing in his kids
education with the idea of getting him a
government job and you know his mom is
okay with that they're a mixed couple by
the way not just in terms of like ethnic
background but in terms of religion as
dad as a pagan Monica is a Catholic
Christian and so you know actually
Patricius likes to you know have a good
time too and doesn't sound like Monica
really does much
oh she was probably higher class than
him oh well they were educated but but
that didn't necessarily put you into the
the upper class but I mean you could
think of this going to study paying to
go study as a way to move up the class
ladder right I mean it used to be for us
it doesn't work quite as well now
anymore although colleges still tell all
the kids that that's going to happen for
them so then he actually he has a year
what we now call a gap year right when
he said well the money runs out right
and so his dad is working and there's
another guy local who also chips in some
money and you know he lives kind of a
wild life that he describes in the
confessions you know they're doing
things like stealing pears and not
stealing him to eat them just for the
sheer sake of stealing pears you know
they're they're engaging in juvenile
delinquency Wow he goes he goes to
college in Carthage but Carthage think
of Carthage I mean it really was in some
respect like the Seattle that mr.
Lorenzo was describing Carthage is the
place where you can do anything you like
you know there's there's gladiatorial
games to watch and you know all sorts of
you know drinking that can goes on and
and he gets involved in this love affair
we never actually find out her name we
do know the name of his son but we don't
know her name and you know he he's
actually a very attached to this
mistress for years and years and years a
day optus is born
Augustine's father dies Augustine joins
the Manicheans and then something
happens he reads this book the Hortensia
switch we don't have anymore cicero
wrote it and it's sort of you know one
of these what we call hortatory text
it's hey well you should study
philosophy here's why and it gives you a
little introduction to it and there were
a lot of
like this in ancient times Augustin
reads it and decides he wants to pursue
real wisdom it doesn't know what it is
yet but he knows that it's not going to
lie in a civil service career like
somebody saying you know I know you know
real wisdom does not lie on the factory
floor or in the post office or you know
on the twelfth floor of the you know
first Wisconsin building or something
like that right
and so he goes back home to the gas
State and he teaches grammar there
he doesn't like teaching much he writes
quite a bit about how awful the students
work please be young young boys you know
and they you know they're like students
they screw around they don't do their
work well they don't steal his parents'
because he doesn't have any but I'm sure
they pull other tricks and then he he
ends up going to Carthage to teach
rhetoric and he founds a school there
and then he hasn't even worst time
students are also not not particularly
motivated and then eventually he goes to
Rome so he's kind of moving up and in
Rome he finds out that the students will
pull it dirty trick on you which is they
pay at the end of the semester this is a
terrible idea
so they attend the whole time and then
the last day of class they don't show up
and they don't pay there isn't really
not much that you can do he meets this
guy Samak as' and so Marcus has a lot of
juice has a lot of pull now it may sound
like a demotion to go from Rome to Milan
but Milan was becoming more important
than Rome at that time in part you know
think about it like Rome is an old city
and it had been an administrative center
but things just don't work that as well
there a lot of times you know Imperial
administrations will like to move to
other locations and so Milan is assuming
form
or importance he starts to study
philosophy he studies the neoplatonist
his mom comes to Rome
Augustine gets gets you know betrothed
to this this 10 year old girl you know
and you know unfortunately he's like
well this is gonna take a while but he
puts aside his his his longtime lover
and this is a very hard thing for him to
do you know he's he's very unhappy about
it she's presumably very unhappy about
it as well but then he starts up with a
new woman never does marry this this
this this young arranged bride or
anything like that and then you know he
starts I mean the entire time he's been
seeking he's been looking for her for
truth wisdom but he's looking for it not
just you know in an abstract way he
wants something that's gonna like
totally inform his life something all he
can also share with other people
oh no he was definitely sponsored him
yeah yeah you could say it you could
call him like he's the he's a patron he
finds out about these desert monks in
Egypt by that time monasticism is really
taking off and Egypt is the place to go
because they're stricter than everybody
else
and Monica his mother dies he decides to
start living as a celibate he starts to
investigate monastic communities in Rome
he's getting more and more attracted to
this and then he leaves forth aghast and
he lives there with his son and
unfortunately two years later his son
dies and you know in some ways this is
kind of a you know he's lost lover he's
lost his his family he's now lost his
son but it's an opportunity for him to
sort of settle his affairs straighten
everything out in terms of the family
property which he does and then you know
Augustine will do this at several points
when he's feeling too miserable because
of something like a grief over over
he'll he'll travel somewhere else so he
goes to hippo and there in hippo he is
ordained as a priest and it's not
something that he's particularly
interested in doing but he's starting to
get a reputation and the congregation
there thinks it's a good idea so they
decided for him and you notice now he
starts to do a lot more things within
the church he addresses the council and
hippo
he begins fighting the Donatists not
literally although they do try to kill
him at one point eventually he becomes
the coadjutor which is sort of like an
assistant sort of like what are we you
know nowadays they call it an auxilary
Bishop like a bishop who works with the
archbishop or the Monsignor right and in
a Catholic community the Monsignor
it's it's not technically like higher
than a priest as far as role goes but if
your mind senior you're probably going
to be a bishop right it's usually the
way it works and then the bishop dies
and then the bishop by the way I should
mention there's there's another bishop
besides the one in hippo who I kind of
skipped over and that's Ambrose Ambrose
is one of the fathers of the church and
park as he writes important stuff but
he's also very politically active
Ambrose is in Milan remember I said
Milan was a really important City and
Ambrose has a lot of sway on the
Emperor's themselves so he's important
not just from a doctrinal perspective
but also from a political perspective
Augustine you know develops under him so
Augustine gets to see how power is
exercised how you you know follow out
these connections he sees Ambrose
Ambrose is also very committed to try to
make Orthodox Christianity the only game
in town not only does he combat the the
other Christian
we've used as heretics he also does his
best to see both pagan temples and
things like that
closed up if he can't but also Jewish
synagogues so Augustine becomes a bishop
himself after Valerius dies and you can
see you know I only put a few of his
works here but and I only put when they
started yet obviously in have a tendency
to write part of a work and then I got
other stuff to do and they can come back
to it sometimes years later and finish
up the work so for example well the City
of God right City of God he begins work
in 4:13 he doesn't finish it for like
another you know 10 years so when when
should we actually say the book was
published it's a little hard to say you
know it's not it's not like today's
stuff we're generally you say when the
book actually came out because parts of
it are coming well that's a good
question I don't think I don't know that
we have anything like that because we
don't we don't really have much from
that time period of original manuscripts
for later stuff we sometimes do have
like it's not a first draft but it's
like you know kind of unfinished and
then finished drafts but that that's
much later and that's because somebody
thought to keep that stuff generally
because the work of copying and so
production was was labor-intensive and
also a material intensive you wouldn't
copy stuff unless you thought it was
really worth doing you know so but I
mean there must have been copies around
his experience over like a 10-year
period
sadly influence he's right well they
happen deepening its thinking and stuff
like that yeah
I mean part of it is like writing like
this this book which means thrust this
chapter first and being done with that
and then coming back to it and writing
the next chapter yeah
and so like on free trace of the will he
does that right book one and then comes
back and writes books books two and
three is there is there often like a
great development well he's usually put
off the more important topics for books
so I don't know maybe maybe that maybe
that is the case now he he gets to see
Rome fall which happens in 410 this
Gothic general Alaric and his men sacrum
and Y Justine lives for another 20 years
after that yeah you see yeah yeah he's
got a pretty pretty long life I mean you
know that's an interesting point so this
is not really related to Augustine but
if you made it through the childhood
diseases and you didn't have some
something that would eventually like
kill you in your 30s and you didn't run
into pirates or fire or pick whatever
else you know warriors coming through
you probably could live into your
seventies yeah I mean if you took care
of yourself if you were a hard drinker
probably not right I mean they didn't
have smoking back then which we know now
is you know quite the ad for you and you
know it wasn't very hard to get exercise
back then either
compared to now either so if you took
care of yourself yeah you could live
into your 70s you know yeah
do you think that by being a bishop well
so that's an interesting question let me
talk about like the open-mindedness
aspect of it so Augustine is he's not
like some of the writers of his time
some of the Christian thinkers of his
time who are quite frankly close-minded
he he's more like some of the other
Christian philosophers who think that
there's really something valuable there
in pre-christian Greek philosophy but it
has to be reinterpreted within a
Christian context and he thinks that the
plate Nasseri common attitude within
Christian philosophy and like the first
say five six centuries they thought the
plate inist got closest to it so
actually this is a good segue into
talking a little bit about the
philosophical scene of the time and this
might answer the question well so I you
know I put on this this handout these 5
philosophical schools of antiquity Plato
starts you know his school the Academy
and you know it remained platonic for a
while then the skeptics took it over
they're also called academics and then
the plate mistook it back and so by the
time that Augustine is on the scene
you really got century after century
after century of thinkers after Plato's
still following out this course and and
their view was that you know what was
most real was not matter where the body
it was spirit and ultimately it was this
this thing the one that we would get to
know through contemplation for
Christians of course that's God right
and there were not just Christian
neoplatonist they were also pagan
neoplatonist there were Jewish
neoplatonist like feel of Alexandria so
that's one school there's also the
Aristotelian 's
really they didn't have that much roll
by the time that Augustine is writing
they a lot of what they were doing would
get kind of sucked into Neoplatonic
philosophy the neo plaintiffs would say
you got Plato for everything from like
the human being on up to God and then
for everything of this realm well you
got Aristotle he explains biology just
fine or the human emotions with
psychology he's good for that stuff but
then when it comes to the metaphysics I
had don't listen to him listen to play
it on stud right and so some of the Neo
plaintiffs would do that with Aristotle
some of them would do that with the
Stoics the Stoics also we're good at you
know providing an explanation of the
sublunar airy realm you know the realm
that includes us and the Stoics were
persuasive and powerful school very very
attractive to many people in the Roman
Empire they stressed you know virtue as
the only good duty you know the the the
overcoming negative emotions you know
fulfilling your place within the larger
cosmos and they were materialists so the
Christians wouldn't get in in alignment
with them on that but they did borrow a
lot from the Stoics you can see if you
look at monastic literature and then you
look at some of the things that stomachs
we're doing you see similar discussions
where and so it looks like they've
probably borrowed some ideas from them
and then we have the skeptics Augustine
actually writes one were against the
academics against the skeptics the
skeptics were these people who thought
you can't really know anything for sure
for any argument you can always find an
equal argument to bring up and they
spent a lot of time doing that and you
know their idea was maybe we'll someday
find knowledge the Christians tended to
reject that they said these guys are
engaging in skepticism for its own sake
they're going too far with it and then
there's the Epicureans everybody hated
the Epicureans except for Epicureans the
Epicureans were materialists
they really get a bad rap much much more
than they deserve they were focused on
they thought pleasure and pain are the
ultimate goods and evils and so the goal
is to live a life that's you know free
of pain and trouble a nice life it
doesn't mean like you know getting drunk
every night and you know sleeping around
like that
that's not a fad Kurian because those
are the sort of things right what
happens when you get drunk you can
hungover right or you do dumb stuff like
crash your car what happens if you sleep
around you know you're bound to run into
some jilted spouse at one point or
another it may pop you in the face
that's going to cause pain so the
Epicureans they weren't really hell
raisers or anything but because they
were materialists and because they are
devoted to a life of the senses
everybody not just that not just the the
Christians but all the other schools
sort of picked on them too and said you
I don't don't be an Epicure as a matter
of fact in the tall wood at one point
epicurean is used as a synonym for
materialist philosophers so everybody
thought that they were they ever been
and so now where does Augustine fit in
with this so the Christian philosophers
some of them thought philosophy is just
terrible right they're not philosophers
then you know Tertullian has this famous
line I believe because it's absurd the
other thing that he says is you know
what does Athens have to do with
Jerusalem right you got Christianity
over here religious belief then you got
those dirty philosophers over here with
their reason and you know and you know
st. Paul said don't be deceived by vain
philosophies so get rid of the
philosophy stuff there were also a lot
of people who were Christian
philosophers Justin Martyr locked on
seus clement of alexandria who's before
augustine is a great example of somebody
who thought that greek philosophy could
actually be very productive he says
maybe Greek philosophy for the Greeks
has the same function that you know what
the Christians were calling the Old
Testament had for the Jews it was a
preparation for the gospel that's I
think it's kind of optimistic because
that sounds if all the Greeks were
reading Greek laws but the idea was you
could take these you could take the
heritage of all these thoughts and
what's useful in that and bring them
into a greater synthesis that would
include you know Christian scripture but
not understood it's sort of a
fundamentalist way where like you just
whip out the scripture quotes and you
don't think about it you you wanted to
think out the big questions like where
did evil come from what you know what
are we supposed to be doing how should
we orient ourselves towards the the
political rule should we be obeying them
should we be disobeying them what's the
nature of God you know who is the
universe created or is it eternal and
then one of the fundamental questions
why the hell can't I do what I know I'm
supposed to do
and so philosophy could be used
it could be harnessed and brought within
this Christian perspective to provide a
greater intelligibility a greater
understanding and so to you know is
being a Christian Bishop preventing
Augustine from doing that it doesn't
stand in the way at all he does think
that you do have to reject you have to
be very careful about what you accept
and you have to reject some things from
the pagans so in the City of God for
example one of the one of the things I
sometimes teach to my ethics students he
talks about the virtues of the pagans
being splendid vices and what he means
by that is they they kind of get things
right but because they don't get things
completely right it inevitably is going
to go wrong so the virtues that the
pagans extolled wind up they wind up
producing the wrong result
and people are prideful because of the
and he's not unique among among early
Christian authors and pointing this out
now there's another constraint though if
you're a bishop do you actually have
time right - to be a bishop if you're
taking the job seriously it's a big
commitment I sure saw wouldn't want to
be a bishop because you know you're
you're the top guy in that area the
bishop is supposed to be the overseer
the Pisgah posts literally though the
the one who looks over all the priests
he's supposed to be in charge of making
sure doctrine has actually followed me
and you think about the sort of stuff
that you have to pay attention to all
these disciplinary matters you know one
of the other guys try to work on his
Anselm of Canterbury and we have his
letters we have a lot of Augustine's
letters - but a good number of Anselm's
letters as he moves up in the hierarchy
are things like don't let that priest go
into town because when he does he gets
drunk and then he looks like a jerk you
know he makes us all look bad
this guy over here is not supposed to be
married yeah I mean no I mean I you
wonder when he actually had the time to
do this sort of stuff you know so some
of the old depictions you see in there
as we've got you know that night and
there's a lamp and he's like against the
head like this you could imagine that
could be from being a bishop not just
from trying to figure out philosophical
problems so yeah so that's that's a good
good part of it let's talk about some of
his key ideas so I mentioned the
question of why do we do the wrong stuff
that's something that preoccupies
Augustine and there's there's really two
sides to this one side is sort of the
big picture
how did evil come into the the universe
you know is it the devil why'd God
create the devil in such a way that he
could you know do the wrong thing and
the Manicheans I mentioned you know I
guess didn't belong to this sect they
had some sort of explanation for it that
he thought made sense for a while which
is that you know God actually didn't
create everything there's there's
something else that that resists God and
we have to purify ourselves and that's
matter and we want to be pure spiritual
beings and then we won't be evil the the
you know obviously you didn't think this
really explained that much one of the
other beefs that he had with the
Manicheans because they had lots and
lots of explanations but when you added
them up together they didn't really fit
they weren't they weren't consistent
with each other and so he tried to get
clarification from a Manichaean bishop
named Faustus and he couldn't get any
answers that really satisfied him and
that's when he left shortly afterwards
he left the Manichaean Church he didn't
you know automatically just then become
a Catholic he was seeking around he
wanted some sort of explanation of how
you know evil could be and one of the
answers for this one part of the answer
evil is not something that is it's
something that reflects a lack or a
corruption or something that's missing
evil is the absence or the corruption or
the perversion of the good ultimately
according to Augustine everything really
is good so even that very safe that's
going to kill us you know it's good
insofar as it's a virus it's bad insofar
as it's in me and multiplying and making
my nose run or whatever else it's going
to do to me right another good example
would be like those prion diseases
going to our brains and they do that
weird thing with the protein and then
they mess up our brains in ways that
can't be fixed we look at that as bad
right but it's bad relative to us it's
bad within this this particular context
now you know when we get to human beings
we do a lot of dumb stuff and we we hurt
each other and we we know there's rules
and we break the rules and so you can
say well what about that stuff right and
well I guess Tina has an answer for that
free will
human beings are endowed with the choice
of doing the right thing or not doing
the right thing and much of the time
when we do the wrong thing
it's because we choose it sometimes we
don't actually know what we're choosing
but but a good bit of the time we
actually you know you mate say oh I
didn't know that it would work out this
way but you know if you you know do
something that you know is going to tick
somebody off because they don't like you
saying that thing to that or doing that
thing to they you you know something's
gonna happen right now you might say
well why the hell would God create human
beings like this guy could have created
us in any particular way why didn't he
just like give us you know good
governor's like in our brains or
something so like as soon as and this is
gonna be a very oversimplified but like
as soon as I would start thinking about
you know I don't like this thing my wife
said to me just now I'm gonna say
something mean to her it would say nope
don't do that
you know let's put some happy thoughts
in there instead well Augustine says it
wouldn't be much of a human being now
would it
there'd be something missing the way
that he expresses it is freewill is such
a such a great good that it makes sense
if you think it through for God to
create beings with freewill even if he
knows that they're gonna screw it up
which includes not just us too but also
you know the Angels at least with us you
can say
our bodies you know they they make us
like you know I'll do do things for
greed because we want to feed ourselves
or for lost or for these other things
that move our bodies the Angels don't
have any excuses like that you know they
have free will though so you know that
that's part of the answer to the issue
of evil it's not a totally satisfying
one for for many people but Oh some
kinds of good so you know this podium
doesn't have free will it doesn't even
have sentience right it's just a dumb
mute object but insofar as it is what it
is it's good
Augustine would say oh yeah yeah
everything insofar as it as being is
good in some way this is not remotely
close to the kind of good that you and I
are and in order to be the kinds of
things that we are we have to have free
will if you know somehow we could take
the freewill out of you or out of me we
would we would still be good our bodies
would still be you know this wonderful
construction you know our well that's
one type of good good means many things
you know good is what we call a
ambiguous term right number of different
words
sure value judgment about about
something that that happens to be the
case you know and you know he's not
saying just good for something in he's
saying insofar as it exists it's
something good everything is that way
even down to you know things like a clot
of mud you know on the bottom of my shoe
that's not very good
we got to keep things in perspective
but I mean that's one of the key ideas
one of the so going back to this now why
don't we do the right thing if we have a
free will why can't I just like will to
do the good thing why why do I find
myself in Scituate
of temptation even if I have like you
know prepared myself ahead of time and I
know what all the stakes are why do i
every once in a while just like you know
say something that I know is gonna tick
somebody off and I know I shouldn't say
it and I tell myself don't say that why
can't I make that not happen Augustine
says we need something besides just
choice we need divine aid we need grace
and now how exactly grace helps us out
there it gets trickier right but he says
that that that's something that we need
and he struggled with this for himself
for years you know he said his big thing
was lost right you guys never heard that
lord give me continents but not yet
praise you know he wanted to quit
screwing around just not to be too blunt
about it and he found himself over and
over again falling and he was like what
the hell's wrong with me you know I know
I'm not supposed to be doing this I want
to be you know on the right track to God
God give me countenance
not quite yet though I want to still
enjoy it and then he finally has this
this crisis and in a garden and he's
given the grace that he needs this would
be oh he's that is yeah the know was
long before that this is the early on
actually in his life
oh yeah this is 386 yeah yeah I mean you
could say before the losses some people
the lust no longer is an issue because
they are all right they don't have those
desires that he wore no he's still like
like yeah yeah well the happy life for
him is one that's that's free and all of
these these sorts of issues but that's
that that's a really key issue for him
another thing we can say about him is he
he spends a lot of time analyzing what
we would call the will he's one of the
great theoreticians of the human will or
if you like the human heart and so this
is kind of a good jumping-off point to
talk about his influence so he you know
as a bishop he had a lot of influence
locally
he writes important doctorate they're
not the important treaty C's and letters
against these different heresies and you
know that would make him kind of a
second-rate figure as far as the history
of ideas go there's plenty of other
thinkers who did that sort of thing we
have you know a couple letters from this
guy a treatise against these these
people and that probably had some some
usefulness but that's not really what
he's remembered for it's more you know
text like like the confessions or the
City of God or the free choice of the
will and if you think about Augustine
and what he wrote he was a guy we're
talking a little bit about this before
before we started he was a guy who could
like write across genres he wasn't a
one-trick pony he wrote you know
remarkable what would you call this you
know I mean it's called confessions but
it's really like a narrative of a life
with spiritual examination going on and
then there's you know three metaphysical
chapters at the end about time and
memory and creation it's really it
almost its own genre
he writes tree DC's which are you know
sort of treatments of particular topics
about stuff about like you know on lying
is it ever okay to lie you know his
answer is no but sometimes it's worse
than others and he writes a lot of
letters that we've got saved
he writes sermons very important stuff
there cuz you know sometimes you go to a
mass and the priest just wants to tell
jokes or something like that all right
talk about the Packers that maybe
finally gets the talking about the the
readings but really what's supposed to
be happening is sort of a you know a
teaching about what the readings are
really about
that's what Augustine would do but that
was also you know kind of common as well
he he writes dialogues really you know
wonderful actual philosophical dialogues
sometimes when people write
philosophical dialogues it's more like
you know I'm gonna tell you my bit and
then you've got a guy over here who's
like the straight man and a comedy thing
and it says Oh various student
tell me more I'm Augustine's dialogues
are real dialogues you know that takes
some doing to be able to write that sort
of thing
even writes a thing called an end
karidian which is a handbook a little
handbook of Christian doctrine again
tough to do sounds sounds easier I don't
know if I put that on yeah did I yeah
and that that's somebody asked him for
it so he was like yeah I can do that for
you so now his influence
so Augustine leaves behind a large body
of work and much of it survives
we've lost on the beautiful and the
fitting which is something he wrote
early on he may not even have preserved
that himself but most of what he wrote
managed to survive into the Middle Ages
in the West he was not highly regarded
in the East there's a few people who who
mention him but for the most part it's
Latin West and in the Latin West he
becomes one of the most important
Christian thinkers influencing everybody
all the way through the Middle Ages
continuing to influence people through
the Reformation Martin Luther
is an Augustinian monk Martin Luther
thinks that you need to read Augustine
John Calvin who's you know as opposed to
Luther as he is to the Catholic Church
also uses Augustine so you've got these
very interesting reappropriation of
Augustine happening his work is so rich
and because it's not systematic he's the
kind of guy who you could almost find
contradictory ideas within depending on
how you push it right and this continues
on all the way to the president there
there are still people very interested
in Augustine today
confessions is a very common book to
assign not just in religious
institutions but even in in secular
institutions like in an intro to
philosophy class or things like that so
his his thought is is continually being
reappropriation and engaging new
generations of students and and
theologians and philosophers and you
know I think that his influence is going
to continue but let me return his back
to the Middle Ages a little bit there
were other plenty of other thinkers I
mentioned Ambrose he was another person
quite quite often read the guy named
after Gregory the Great another one of
the Western Fathers he was read quite a
lot and you have these these other
people that are considered to be you
know doctors of the church later on
Augustine probably over tops all of them
until the high middle ages
you know when maybe Thomas Aquinas
attains more of a stature but only
within Catholic circles you know and
only some Catholic circles if you're a
Franciscan Augustine is more important
than than Aristotle and Thomas at that
time and then you know later on of
course the Protestants although they are
quite interested in Thomas now perhaps
more so than in some Catholic
institutions strangely enough Augustine
is is sort of the go-to guy for Western
Christianity for Western Christianity
that that knows its roots that remain
there remains in contact with its
heritage he is an important interlocutor
he's an important sort of middle figure
and you mean like the translations oh
yes I mean the confessions there's
there's just one that I happen to have
on my shelf this is the John Ryan you
can also this never let worrying about
the translation keep you from reading
something because you can always read it
and then go get another translation
right but but if you're worried about
well if you're worried about getting
like the right translation you might
never start you know it's one of those
things where here's the other thing I'll
say about translation so I I read much
of my stuff yeah because I can read
Latin and Greek and French and German
now so if somebody comes to me and
they're like is this a good translation
I can sometimes it sometimes it takes a
lot of work especially with somebody
like Augustine who is very very complex
writer but I can puzzle it all they can
be like well I don't know why they
translated it this way because this
seems kind of off and slow like that
that takes a lot of time and I can do
that now if you if you don't have access
to the original you're kind of taking it
on yeah trust right but there's nothing
else you can do so
studying yeah yeah but even then you
know I mean I can read English it very
quickly
reading Latin you know it's much more
slow going
right reading Augustine's Latin is yet
more slow going
oh you know I was in high school you
know I said my mom made me take French
because my family's french-canadian and
I grew up you know speaking some French
at home her generation was you know
French before English and you know I was
a rebellious kid I didn't want to take
any languages I actually had two years
of Latin in middle school and it was
cool it was fun but I didn't I didn't
apply myself I didn't I
I'll tell you I didn't actually this is
totally off topic I didn't apply myself
in any serious way until I got to
graduate school because I could I was
fortunate enough that I could get
through my classes and I didn't shoot
for like getting straight A's I just
needed whatever would keep my mom off my
case
so A's and B's a good mix of those was
fine and honors classes were even better
cuz because if I got a C it counted as a
B right so long as I kept my grade point
average around 3.5 that was fine and
then I had no intention of going to
college went in the army then I went to
college and in college I didn't really
apply myself that much because I could
get by and I like you know having a good
time sort of like yeah sort of like
Augustine and then when I got to
graduate school and I started talking
with some of the other graduate students
I was like exactly these guys are
serious I'm not going to be able to get
away with the same sort of love as I was
able to in the past and then you know it
turned out I hadn't ruined myself so
much that I couldn't apply myself and
then I and then I did and I read a lot
more of Augustine at that time
and he's somebody who I enjoy teaching
this is another thing I hadn't planned
to talk about but I'll mention it I've
taught him trot confessions and I've
taught City of God and I've taught on
the free trace of the will a number of
times and the students have always
seemed to enjoy and get quite a bit out
of it and a lot of discussion takes
place with that but you know it's
interesting some some thinkers are
harder to get the students into and you
wouldn't think that this guy wouldn't
necessarily be an easy sell but he is at
least in my experience yeah very much so
as a matter of fact there's even
something that's called semi-pelagianism
where they think that Augustine himself
went too far in stressing our our
inability to have any role and sort of
saving ourselves or they're like well
can't we you don't kind of prepare the
way for grace at least you know and
semi-pelagianism also got got condemned
it's more of the term that people like
throw at each other absolutely you can
I think that it's kind of a freak yeah I
think for some people the the view so
Augustine he's not unique in thinking
that our human nature is damaged by the
sin of Adam right he does have kind of
an interesting idea about it transmitted
through the seed through the sexual act
and all that sort of stuff being kind of
put that aside right I'd say wow they
had weird ideas about how sex work and
the basic idea is we in you know our our
original nature was was upright and
we're so damaged that we don't even
realize how damaged we are and we don't
have the resources to unscrew ourselves
up so the platoons are saying no that's
not really the case we we've been given
reason we've been given a free will you
know why can't we actually fix ourselves
we're not saying that we're as good as
God but why why can't we actually
they're more optimistic yeah I mean you
mean to take a sort of pessimistic
passive attitude I guess that's it's not
liberating and quite the same way that
little bit it's just sort of thing we're
gonna I'm gonna screw up so I I'm never
gonna trap I mean I myself it's
interesting I think it's GK Chesterton
is the one who said that there's all
these doctrines in Christianity and
people say that you can empirically
prove this one and prove this one the
only one that you can actually
empirically prove is the doctrine of
original sin how so just look around and
I know I'm roughly paraphrasing this
here but the idea is that we are all all
screwed up and it's not like we ever in
our lifetime
had a time when we weren't screwed up we
were just like either we are actively
screwed up or the seeds were already in
us yeah those people I mean you're
constantly striving for perfection yeah
a little perfection I mean that's
stressful and you may never get there
isn't a little bit more free yeah well
so if we use that metaphor with
Augustine and with Christian orthodoxy
you're relying on God to pour in the
other half or you know maybe maybe it's
not half empty
maybe it's like three-quarters I'm who
knows all right but but that's the
that's the idea behind it his grace
comes in to make up what's what's
missing and that allows us to for the
first time actually like see things
rightly we I mean you could say we don't
even realize how messed up we are until
we've been made a little less messed up
you know yeah and then you know there's
all sorts of debates to about like okay
stop does God like totally fix you all
at once
or does he fix you enough so now you can
recognize what a what a screwed up mess
you've made of things and fix a little
bit of it and then it gives you a little
bit more you know I mean I I think well
I mean Augustine would say that if God
wants to save somebody totally like and
completely transforming he's God he can
do that but in general he gives us the
grace that we need and then it's up to
us to do some stuff with it
but we can't do anything without that
original grace for Augustine if we don't
if we don't get that we're just we're
adrift you know and you can't compel God
to give it you know you can't be like
you can't cross some threshold where
that God yes Chris
can you thing out sure that was the case
[Music]
institutions yeah was so all of it so
you know we've talked about the City of
God so the City of God is a book where
he distinguishes between the city of man
the world and the kinds of governance
that we see there and then our heavenly
homeland our you know patria this this
Commonwealth that that everybody within
the religious community ultimately
belongs to including those who have
already died and all that and one of the
fundamental mistakes that we make is
thinking that the city of human beings
can be turned into the City of God like
we can make the world into a utopia now
that doesn't mean that he's just like a
pure pessimist he thinks that there is
some legitimacy to limited legitimacy to
the institutions that exist they're
there to keep things from getting worse
than they are but they're not they're
not ideal and we don't have to pretend
that they are you know so we can obey
the laws now if they're if they're
really unjust laws them then we can
break them you know because they may not
even really be laws that in that case
but for the most part that the
magistrates are there and we got to put
up with them because God you know sort
of like Paul's discussion in his letters
he says you know the magistrates are
there and God put them there even if
they're complete you know idiots they're
serving some sort of purpose but we
should never take the earthly thing as
being you know the heavenly and when it
comes to things like inequality or
social stratification
those are things that we can try to
change but it's sort of like with with
the original sin thing when no scheme by
which we try to fix them is ever going
to completely fix them that doesn't mean
that we have to say well screw it then
don't don't do anything let's let you
know the rich and the powerful oppress
the poor know try to rein them in just
realize it's probably not going to work
that much and sooner or later some poor
guy is gonna be the next rich guy and
he's gonna be just as oppressive so
you're kind of condemned to this
cyclical thing so I suppose if you were
an Augustinian you know somebody who's
very Augustinian in that respect
Reinhold Niebuhr he's got this book
moral man and immoral society that was
very influential like you know through
the 60s and the idea is that no earthly
human institution ever fully measures up
to what it was intended to do so let's
say we you know think about equal
opportunity right we we had we had a
very unjust society particularly in
terms of race here in the United States
we create equal opportunity measures do
they fix everything no they they fix
some things and then some people figure
out how to game the system and other
people become dependent upon it and it
you know causes other people to feel
like they've been shut out you know so
it's always a matter of trade-offs you
know we can only get good things a bit
better we can't make them completely
better here in in terms of politics at
least you know it doesn't mean we can't
live good lives people but you know
that's not going to automatically be the
leaven that you know fixes the whole
society or something like that but
really very realistic in a way you
almost have a from livestreams
perspective you almost have a
requirement to be realistic right
because if you're being sort of
pie-in-the-sky idealist about it you're
gonna you're going to do something for a
little while then you're going to get
dismayed at the fact that it doesn't
work and then you're gonna withdraw from
doing what you're supposed to be doing
so yeah I don't know does that answer
the question okay yeah well we should
probably finish up do you guys have any
questions you want to ask no no it's
it's it's really you know think of it as
like there's a city up here and we don't
really we only glimpse that a little bit
that's the spiritual city that we can
all belong to and then there's the whole
mess of this stuff down here the city of
man that we can see and touch and feel
so I mean this is Dickens referencing
them at all maybe I don't know I'm sure
yeah